vous êtes fiancée à rosny qui est dans
le couloir de la mort en floride en
floride depuis trente ans il y un an et
demi vous avez fait la démarche de
vouloir parler à des condamnés à mort
américains
on ne parlait pas anglais donc vous vous
êtes rendu aux états unis vous avez
parlé avec donc des des salades et des
condamnés à mort américains c'est ça non
j'ai demandé un correspondant d'accord
qui m'a été attribué par hasard total et
donc mais voilà c'est ronnie alors c'est
ronnie ouais c'était pas du tout une
démarche amorosa n'ont pas vraiment
métier marié vous avez quatre enfants et
vous avez tout quitté pour venir faire
votre mari pour renie pas mes enfants
mais bien sûr j'ai vraiment bon
vous avez quitté votre mari pour renault
oui mais vous l'avez déjà rencontré je
les ai rencontrés une fois avant way we
et comment ça s'est passé en fait vous
parlé avec lui par message c'est ça oui
il ya des systèmes dits mail qui sont
pas des systèmes dits mail classique
comme on pourrait avoir
et vous êtes tombé amoureux du point oui
bon c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
je vais pas m'étendre sur le sujet voilà
mais c'est vrai que
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont fait
mais après quand on me dit vous avez
tout quitter pour un condamné à mort non
j'ai quitté mon mari pour un autre homme
cya il les connaît bien beau mais vous
avez vous avez vous avez jamais eu de
relation avec lui et donc oui cc voilà
donc vous avez quel type de relation et
que vous lui parlez tous les jours on se
parle tous les jours plusieurs fois par
jour on partage des moments du quotidien
on convient de certaines heures où on va
se dire bah tiens là on va faire du
sport ensemble à telle heure on n'écoute
pas la même musique fin après on essaye
de faire comme on peut avec ce qu'on a
parce que c'est relativement restreint
je dirais tu devras tonique surtout
là-bas je suis chaud il est condamné à
mort pour moi c'est quand même heure
soit lanners d'un homme un homme
j'aime pas le dédramatiser la mres ça
reste les meurtres un 2ème édition saga
pas un crime barbare je dirais voilà
c'est quoi ça
il a quand même pas dire mais bon c'est
non non pas du tout c'est ils étaient
jeunes ils sont deux alors après c'est
un procès très controversé je vais pas
rentrer là dedans il ya de gros
problèmes aux états unis au niveau de
ses procès et surtout quand on remonte
dans ces années là il ya un coaccusé co
accusés qui avaient beaucoup plus
d'argent qu'on soit bref le couac il a
fait 25 ans pour vous dire les témoin
clé du procès c'est quand même la mère
et la soeur du coaccusé donc déjà qu'on
nous avait dit ça il ya quand même un
problème soit donc après techniquement
le crime pour lequel il a été condamné à
mort c'est le meurtre d'un autre homme
ils étaient drogués ils étaient
alcoolisés ils ont été pris en stop par
un homme et
et voilà c'est parce qu'il avait un
passé ou pas alors il a tué donc
quelqu'un dans les années 80 il attend
son exécution depuis plus de 30 ans oui
il a épuisé tous les recours
oui vous devez vous marier prochainement
oui qu'annoncé entière ouvriront dès que
vous avez le droit de l'autorisation de
la prison qu'on aura sans problème
particulier mais bon là on est coincé
avec les frontières ils doivent me dont
ils ont ils en sont pour rony c'est ça
va ça va se passer quand son exécution
ça on peut pas le savoir alors d'un état
à un autre c'est très variable au texas
vous avez les dates un an deux ans à
l'avance parfois en floride ces 30 jours
y est exceptionnellement parfois des
mandats de 75 jours ça peut arriver mais
en général c'est 30 jours ça veut dire 3
du 30 jours avons donc en jours avant on
vous dit le mandat était signée donc
dans 30 jours vous serez exécuté bien
sûr vous avez des possibilités d'essayer
de vous battre mais bon la clémence là
bas dans les états du sud
ça n'arrive que très très rarement voilà
donc alors vous dites que quand vous
entendez parler de peine de mort en
france
comprenez pas dead et vous est terrifiée
ça me fait peur alors je peux l'entendre
parce que le c'est un cri du coeur des
français et ça je le comprends quand
vous entendez le témoignage de mustapha
ben a raison mais je le comprends
totalement et on en a un petit peu parlé
tout à l'heure en aparté voilà je je
peux pas nier en bloc et lui dire que je
comprends pas ce que vous ressentez bon
moi j'ai quatre enfants dont trois
filles voilà demain on fait quelque
chose à mon enfant évidemment c'est ses
impacts ans mais pour moi la peine de
mort c'est pas la réponse
c'est pas la réponse c'est quelque chose
que les français disent déjà les
français n'ont pas de données puisque
pour la plupart ces voix là c'est
quelque chose qu'on pratique plus depuis
des années c'est la réalité de la peine
de mort les gens ils pensent que c'est
une condamnation une exécution mais il
ya un chemin entre ces deux éléments là
et ça il faut quand même le souligner et
le chemin est long et il sera long en
france aussi si demain on rétablissait
la peine de mort on exécute rapala
personnes trois ou quatre mois après
faut être clair ça n'arrivera pas
on va pas faire comme en chine donc il
va y avoir des années d'incarcération
un des arguments que donnent les jambes
qui sont pros peine de mort c'est non la
prison a vu à perpétuité ça ne va pas on
va pas les nourrir jusqu'à ce qu'il
décède alors ça c'est un argument qui
est démontable par les chiffres
un condamné à mort coûte beaucoup plus
cher et quand je dis beaucoup plus cher
c'est entre deux et demi à trois fois
plus qu'un condamné à perpétuité sans
possibilité de libération j'entends bien
moi je suis favorable à cette semaine
aux financiers sans possibilité de
libération
mais le fait de dire on va pas les
nourrir jusqu'à c'est faux parce que de
toute façon nous aurons moins de 10 ou
15 ans d'incarcération avant que la
peine soit piqué et ça c'est un fait
certain passe avec le système juridique
qu'on a ce sera impossible d'exécuter
les gens comme sans concours de
recomposer dieu merci quand même
mais voilà vous vous disiez qu'on peut
pas comparer que les états unis je suis
d'accord on ne peut pas comparer sur
tous les points mais il ya certains
points
voilà et la peine de mort elle est
appliquée en chine au vietnam en iran en
irak dont on sera plus proche du système
américain que du système irakiens n'ont
existé marocain probablement mais pas du
général ne sera pas plus proche du
système je n'ai pas dit qu'on serait
pareil on n'en serait plus proche du
système américain fait des moratoires
réguliers sur les exécutions donc ça
fait dur c'est-à-dire établi déjà y aura
un état puis son départ à un état qui
est pareil et après vous citiez un
argument sur le l'aspect dissuasif et
des gens ça aussi c'est le deuxième gros
arguments des gens qui sont pour la
peine de mort il dit si la personne
pense qu'elles risquent la peine de mort
il y aura moins de crimes
c'est absolument faux faux et trois fois
faut donc quand vous prenez
désolé mais quand vous prenez les états
unis le taux de crimes années de
criminalité le taux de meurtres le plus
important c'est dans les états du sud
les états du sud représentent 80% des
personnes exécutées les états du
nord-est c'est là où il ya le taux de
meurtres le moins important c'est 0 5%
des aigles d'accord
donc vous voyez bien elle un fils de
risque est là leurs mots forts mais mes
larmes à face à un autre problème celui
dans les états du sud que se concentrent
eux aussi aujourd'hui on a quand même
des problèmes aujourd'hui de crime
et de meurtres en france et on n'a pas
les armes légaliser cela il faut laisser
passer pas le même taux qu'aux états
unis madame évidemment le claudine juste
vous votre votre avenir donc il y avait
qu il avec ronnie comme vous pouvez
recevoir votre avenir avec une personne
en sachant qu'il est condamné à mort bah
écoutez c'est quelque chose au début
auquel on pense souvent
et puis après c'est quelque chose qu'on
finit par oublier oublié je m'entende
c'est vraiment votre homme tout est
complètement ça c'est mais je voudrais
rencontrer dans la rue ça aurait été la
même chose je vois là j'aime quand même
le préciser parce que on est toujours en
train de me stigmatise et sur la je ne
souffre pas de biberist o fili je
précise donc en fait voilà donc vous
êtes vraiment amoureuse de lui mais
j'avais un espoir au fond de vous ou pas
du tout non non on a souvent vous
redoutez juste le moment où on va vous
dire il reste 30 jours je suis assez
optimiste dans le sens où vous savez les
exécutions aux états unis et c'est un
danger je pense aussi pour la france
c'est quelque chose de très politisé
d'accord que ce soit petite échelle par
les gouverneurs ou plus récemment on l'a
vu avec les exécutions fédéral qui ont
repris après 17 ans d'inactivité pour
des campagnes plus grosse à l'arrivée un
gouverneur il va pas exécuter quelqu'un
avec lequel il va pas avoir de
retentissement médiatique d'accord sans
faute et que sassou vraiment ils
exécutent énormément mais quand vous
prenez la floride déjà la floride je
vais vous expliquer il ya quand même
plus de 340 condamné à mort en floride
aujourd'hui ils exécutent entre trois et
quatre personnes par an d'accord donc
vous imaginez quand même que sur le lot
il y en a quand même beaucoup qui vont
finir leurs jours en prison
bien sûr ça c'est un fait ils sont
exécutés comme je vous dis plus pour
faire un retentissement médiatique
tiens lui il a fait tant de meurtre
s'était il a terrorisé une génération
etc on exécute lui s'attaquer aux
homosexuels on l'exécuté le cas de mon
fiancé c'est si j'ose dire pas un cas
grave si on le compare je dirais aux
autres donc j'ai un peu d'espoir la
seule chose qui me fait peur c'est que
demain on est un gouverneur qui arrive
qu'ils étaient comme le précédent qu'on
avait en floride et qui disent bon là on
va faire un peu le ménage ceux qui sont
là depuis longtemps
on va liquider ça c'est un risque